my mother did a local news story telling
everyone that she had stage three cancer
that she was going to die she did not
have cancer
that plucked ways
can you believe a person like this is
lying Ken hey
don't want to judge a book by its cover
but hey there smoke skin Karen level
500. she wants to speak
to all the managers and she'll take him
out too
today we're watching Dr Phil with candy
someone is lying but we don't know who
let's check it out in the news my mom
said that she's had 17 Strokes she told
them that her face was removed and put
back on
it's just like Face-Off with Nicholas
Cage
it's all making sense now ah now it's
all coming together okay I thought she
looked like she does naturally that's
her post face being pulled off gotcha
okay you know if I had the opportunity
to take my face off and put it back on I
don't know if I would have picked that
one
I decided to write the Dr Phil show
because my mom wants attention she wants
a show then let's give her a show wow
that makes too much sense yeah oh you're
a drug you're a drug addict okay well
here's every single drug ha got you like
how she's the victim in this too like I
cannot stand by and let my mother lie
anymore Aiden I must stop her the only
way Dr Phil
I can't think of anyway
bro just delete her phone number
it's okay to not speak to your parents
it's fun oh man
[Laughter]
leave her yep
the plot twist sisters are lying she's
just a hater
before we continue quick word from
sponsor guys I have so much money and
nowhere to soar it let's get real here
wallets are way too clunky I've tried
some unconventional methods of sorting
my money I would not recommend it
thankfully the ridge wallet is here ah
so tiny so small
as an epic minimalist I approve easily
access all your cards
it can even store your cash with the
flap thing there's so many goddamn cards
in Japan but I need them
to go to the arcade if you're thinking
about changing your wallet definitely
recommend it as a lifetime warranty go
to richwallet.com PewDiePie and you will
get 40 off you are welcome say thank you
[Music]
okay they also have oh my God I am so
happy about that bridge wallet they just
get me okay I hate keychains I hate how
they feel in my pocket Rich wallet easy
way to store your keys it feels really
good and of course it's amazing in your
pocket it doesn't take up more space
than it should thank you I also kiss you
twice actually
I don't say it looks good too so yeah if
you're interested I recommend it the
wall is come in a ton of different
colors check it out and also get this
lifetime warranty
stop changing wallets that's cringe and
check out the keychain 40 off rich.com
PewDiePie you're welcome say thanks
look I'm a little scared right now okay
I'm just saying she wants a show then
let's give her a show I need Dr Phil's
help to tell her that she in fact does
not have cancer and that what she is
doing is wrong
ah
I still believe her how can you not
believe her he's an angel I can't
believe a face like that I mean come on
this is your own mother yeah that's my
mother okay now she says that she had
major brain surgery brain cancer
has flatlined twice in the last few
months actually and you don't much care
I do care about my mom Karen I have to
put her on television and then crazy
work whoa whoa whoa Dr Phil hold I do
care don't be it'll be gas like me
please
she had an AVM which is a male formation
of blood vessels that were in her head
and one did come open and it caused it
caused a small bleed in her head and I
went to the hospital I was there for her
and then she kind of turned it into
something that it wasn't she kind of
turned it into cancer but she never had
cancer
as far as you know what do you mean as
far as you know have you seen the cane
sir how can you know it's real if you
haven't seen it am I am I've only one
getting the Bobs here the doctor feels
like suspicious of her for some reason
it's like yeah I'm with I'm with her
as far as far as you know who she is and
what do you know you're not a doctor if
I can't see it it can't be real you're
right like ninjas they're not real can't
see them
that's true ninjas aren't real just like
the Earth is flat because I can't tell
that it's round so therefore it's a
really shitty thing to lie about having
cancer that's like the lowest thing you
could go I think there's gonna be a
significant amount that has done it fake
it yeah oh yeah I think so oh yeah I
mean people people Jesus
people fake stuff every day you know
your kids aren't real the kids are real
you're right it's just like you know all
those YouTubers has all those fancy cars
in their videos that they rented just
like that I've ruined my family uh my
family okay
but Patricia says her epic Survival
Story should be celebrated do not
criticizing a big Survival Story yes I
believe her my name is Patricia she's a
Survivor titles and weightlifting whoa
whoa did you see that wait she was
lifting dude
[Applause]
[Music]
good thing she had a spotter there to
save her life in case something goes oh
my God I have 12 titles in weightlifting
12 titles
damn what was they giving a title for
like the least weight lifted
17 Strokes brain surgery
17. I believe her I still believe it but
I mean
17 Strokes did she just say that she's
got 12 weightlifting titles she's over
there
17 Strokes yeah she had cancer what else
did you say I have cancer I have had 17
Strokes brain surgery plates in my head
pneumonia collapse lungs okay near death
experiences when I first woke up
only two what about the 17th Street
I don't know and one time I stubbed my
toe I stepped on a Lego once near death
near death it was really rough two
scenarios here equally Pleasant okay
either she's an unluckiest woman that is
still somehow alive
or she's just lying about everything man
I believe I believe this woman all right
you you believe her ow I will not
believe her unreasonable how could you
possibly not believe you seem like what
people look like after they have a
stroke 17 Strokes that's why she had to
have her face removed they told me I
can't lift weights because of my health
conditions the more they told me I can't
the stronger I got I know I look hot
doing this
hell yeah
so hot I am a world champion deadlifter
all right well you can lie about having
17 strokes but you ain't the foreign
I'm just a hater I'm just a hater you're
just a hater that's right I am a world
champion deadlifter my first lift was
225 my second left was 240 and my third
left was 250. well there's enough for my
250s the world record no she didn't say
a record she said she's a world champion
let's women world record that live
694 high schools
he's just a bit off you know he's got a
ways to go
there dead left in one of me you gotta
get at least two of me if you're gonna
be competing you know those four medals
she has golly the Detroit and some other
stuff look one of them's got America and
Canada world champion World Cup World
chat all right you know what I'm back on
board I believe her you convinced me
damn 250 she must be on that g film
you're right every time I go to my
doctor's appointment they say we don't
know why you're still here
we don't know why you're still here
there's literally nothing wrong with you
laughs
my daughter Jessica has not supported me
the hater Jessica is seeking revenge on
me yes saying I do not have cancer I'm a
fake and I am telling lies
yeah look at that 250 right what do you
want revenge on what happened she was a
stolar man stole her man you think so
she's hot look at me duh you're right
all right you're right I would you know
what I I admire her confidence I really
do you get the haircut The Barber and
they say do you like it you say I sure
do and you rock it proudly even though
you
I've definitely had those haircuts came
they definitely have oh my god I've had
one that was ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous what the [ __ ] is that hey
oh what is that what is that hair there
you go and I got you I got you let me
this [ __ ] is just like dude I'm gonna
do something different I'm like okay
cool I can tell uh thanks I look like my
class photo when I was [ __ ] first
grade I got you where's you look just
like me in this picture right here wow
I
[Music]
[Applause]
I never seen you younger
best looks like a kid that plays
Beyblade
[Laughter]
yeah this is me and high school right
here you think you messed this
you gotta look a little too old for high
school but there there he is whoa what
the [ __ ]
you look super old I know it's because
the facial hair you're like you're like
those kids and TV shows that like before
20 year old they're like 30.
I was so proud of that Spike there I was
like the last one in class that got
spiked here because everyone oh yeah and
I finally got mine and I'm like hell
yeah you know I actually practiced that
smile I was like should I show a little
teeth okay how do I do that oh really
yeah yeah
well it's a good picture you did a good
job now we're looking at pictures
someone had us me and you combined to
make a baby and it was like it looked so
good and I was like dude
take our best features you know oh what
a devil that's not it but yes this is
like you with like my facial hairs
oh you know what now that I think about
it I couldn't sympathize this lady you
know I think I believe her now because
I've gone through the same thing I've
had cancer and I've also got had 17 uh
seizures because at one time I had the
same haircut there it is right there
yeah
oh my God
it was my coven cut you know hell yeah
you gotta have that card I'm a Believer
now I'm a Believer
you don't look that bad
sadly this is all we get to know from
this but Dr Phil has the receipts they
got the who's telling the truth place
your bets right now ladies and gentlemen
who's telling me I do know that I have
you know from your hospital here I have
all of the documents here I have your
intake I have your the description get
all the procedure they did not use rods
they did not use wires there is a plate
with some screws where they where they
went in oh that's true okay there is no
mention here of them removing your face
your ear and your jaw what
she also said her ears were removed they
removed her jaw face and job which order
I'm so confused
Cyborg and I've also had my face removed
you know I've had my eyebrows removed I
had a butt to uh change surgery I guess
that's not that weird people do get butt
implants yeah I actually did have my
face pulled back though for one surgery
they had to yeah they had like go up I
had like this uh here here comes the
lines
I got plates and crap in my head uh for
real what yeah so I had like this like
this jaw issue that developed uh it's
kind of hard to explain but they had
like going like cut the the roof
immediately don't believe you can move
it like right up under my nose and so to
get to it they had like peel my lips
back and like pull like they had to like
reattach where my nose is you know
connected right there you removed your
lips yeah they like pulled my whole face
like up like up to my eyebrows like get
in there and like do the stuff that they
need to do oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah so whenever I go to the
dentist and they do like um the x-ray
they go were you in a car accident
because I got like freaking plates and
stuff in my jaw
what happened you just deformed uh yeah
my jaw grew weird when I was growing up
as a kid yeah because you were 32 when
you were 15. yeah yeah that's true
so maybe she just doesn't understand
what the doctors were saying my husband
told me I have not looked at the records
because I don't understand half that
stuff anyway
that's why my head my head was in
bandages
and that's why I couldn't talk she made
the story up after her husband died
right
and you said that you lost
all of this way you said A week and a
half you were in the hospital actually
you were in for six days and you came
out weighing 80 to 90 pounds golly
damn what is
we'll be in that hospital guy yeah he's
lose some weight holy crap next day plan
uh Wayne lies okay she went to that
hospital all the vampires work out and
there's like feeding on her the whole
time you know
I lost 100 pounds you lost 100 pounds in
six days does that make even common
sense to you I don't know I'm not a
doctor well you don't need a doctor to
know you can't lose a hundred pounds in
six days unless they're cutting off body
parts
didn't you hear they took off her ear
they cut her whole face off DOC come on
come on pay attention
I have a question so I lied about all
this and made all this though it's kind
of
[Laughter]
no
I will never be able to trust anyone
again this is news to her this is the
first time she heard about this are you
sure that made this up wow
I guess you're right don't lie about
having a very significant brain surgery
no question about it it was done quickly
and efficiently
I don't know if they did it that well
nothing
why is it I couldn't read why is why is
I couldn't write
ma'am your IQ is 64. okay turns out it
has nothing to do with your brain
surgery it's just your brain
we're climbing on this woman so hard
yeah yeah that's true you saw her a few
days later right oh yeah we got coffee
she was fine she was wearing a hat she
didn't want to bring too much attention
about her scar
I care about you and I do love you but
I'm not gonna sit there and play cancer
Charades with you I think everybody
wants to know their history clearly and
I would think you would want to know
your history clearly so uh don't you
because I don't want to know you don't
want it
I don't want to know
I don't like being confronted with my
charade of uh of Lies could not read
those receipts to me please
it's interesting to me how so many
people lack I don't know in general I
think this is an extreme but like
introspection or like wanting to admit
that they're wrong because then yeah it
will just be a little uncomfortable yeah
some people take it like heavy advantage
of the human nature of just believing
someone like yeah exactly you hear this
like I had cancer and I did all this
stuff oh okay well you know I can't like
say you're aware to that because that
would be yeah exactly no one's ever
gonna go no that's a lie yeah do you
know what that's not talked about enough
I feel like yeah in today's society it's
like
yeah anyone can say anything honestly
I've never I'd never bring this up but I
mean a lot of people have assumed it
about me and I feel like okay now's the
time to talk about it your beard is not
real I knew it I don't have legs
all right
you can't see them you know they're
they're same Ken oh my God I'm so
relieved you said this because I also am
completely dismembered ah well I'm glad
we got this conclusion out together
thank you Ken for joining this video If
you enjoyed
Kids channel
you get the last word
if today's your birthday happy birthday